[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants brossoit
au
patro cet air pur de nos montagnes
ce qu'il me fait du bien j'ai
l'impression de prendre des couleurs
c'est très possible nounours en tout cas
tu as truffe et bien brillantes ou
bon le jeune
homme aux bobos pom-pom boy à je connais
une maman qui va être contente ça va lui
faire plaisir regarde je fais tout
ménage
revault cornichons moi aussi j'ai des
mamans on jette petit salut nous tu dois
savoir faire alors bien sûr
il sait tout faire ce nounours et je
vais t du tien principaux
jeux l'état mhr si nous allions faire un
petit tour
[Musique]
c'est ce qui s'appelle idéal en
2d ce que j'ai dit je ne sais pas quoi
je vais dans la neige un animal pratique
très jolie aussi plein que la neige
c'est une hermine pépite d'or j'ai dit
oui mais elle ne se laisse pas attraper
les trains sauvage
ces pépites 1 elle court tout le temps
pour les animaux mais ils se sauvent et
rennes on attrape aucun bon au long cou
fait-on il faut essuyer les verts mais
fais attention ils sont fragiles
soit sans cran
ou là haut le paquet pas je m'en occupe
un ballet heureux te fais pas mal non
[Musique]
mais
tu l'as viendra demain
pepita record coucou regarde que la
gamine mais si elle veut donner un
baiser la pépite à
opérer partie
une en voilà elle revient
elle pas leur revient
elle donne à pézilla pepita
d'essuyer ses larmes
c'est fini tu crois que j'aurais viendra
vraiment la petite hermione mais oui
quand elle te connaîtra alors tu habites
à l'aller
qu'elle vous la wii demain on mettra
tout en nombre ça vaut mieux oh oui il
ne faut jamais remettre au lendemain ce
que l'on peut faire le jour même
vous avez raison cher dada aussi je vous
confie ce chiffon
bonne nuit nous nous est donné à demain
fait de bourrin
[Rires]
[Musique]
ballan
au
pas lent nounours dites histoire
le pauvre dada lui qui n'aime pas faire
le ménage
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher faites votre toilette et lavez
vous les dents embrasser bien fort vos
parents est fait pour
oh
[Musique]
e
oh
[Applaudissements]
en